ceos and founder ceos are by far the
richest people in the world while there
are some oddballs on the billionaires
list who are directors investors and
even athletes the vast majority are
company leaders
unlike most jobs though company leaders
are rarely paid in cash many of the top
ceos take a cash salary of just one
dollar per year and even for the ceos
that take a moderate cash salary the
cash portion is an extremely small
portion of their total compensation for
example out of their pitch's 281 million
salary in 2019 only 2 million was paid
in cash considering this how do
billionaires even access the
extraordinary wealth they have without
crashing their company's stock and what
about founder ceos that own 40 or 50 of
a massive conglomerate for example
bernard arnold owns 47 of lvmh which
gives him a mind-boggling net worth of
123 billion dollars but is it even
possible for him to cash out well at his
age the answer is probably not but
here's how billionaires access their
paper fortunes and how they live a rich
lifestyle without cash
the first thing to note about most of
these billionaires compensation
structure is that they can't cash out
their salary even if they wanted to this
is especially applicable to non-founder
ceos who don't already have a lot of
equity you see the last thing board
members want is for a ceo who either
quits or is fired under negative
circumstances to dump all of their
shares and crash the stock on their way
out so a restriction they implement to
protect against this is stock vesting
the first type of stock vesting is
time-based stock vesting time-based
stock vesting is usually most common
amongst non-founder ceos as the name
suggests these ceos are restricted from
selling any of their stock compensation
for a set period of time this rule
doesn't just apply to executives either
employees at these companies are
generally subject to similar
restrictions both google and apple for
instance follow a four-year vesting
schedule with a one-year investing clip
for employees the vesting cliff simply
means that you can't sell any of your
stock within the first year and after
that you'll get access to your stock on
a linear basis over the next four years
so really you won't get access to all of
your stock until five years after you're
given that compensation and if you leave
during this time period you of course
lose access to your remaining stock ceos
follow a similar structure but their
investing periods are way larger given
that their compensation is also way
larger for example when tim cook was
hired as ceo in 2011 they gave them 1
million shares of apple but the stock
vesting period was 10 years the first
half million shares would unlock in
august of 2016 and the other half
million would unlock in august of 2021.
this is why we saw insane headlines
about tim cook receiving 750 million
worth of stock last year while this is
technically true it's also kind of
misleading when tim was awarded these
shares in 2011 they were worth 384
million dollars and given a vesting
period of 10 years this basically
translates to 38.4 million dollars per
year which is still an insane amount
but it's nowhere close to 750 million
dollars in a single year
tim actually went ahead and sold this
entire compensation right after he got
it but thanks to the vesting period
apple stock had grown to a point at
which it could easily sustain the
selling pressure and protect shareholder
value
the other most common type of stock
vesting is milestone-based vesting
instead of tying up stock access to a
time period this option ties up stock
access to various milestones this type
of vesting is most common amongst
founders ceos who already have loads of
equity given that they already have
plenty of shares it's not the board
member's top concern to get these ceos
even more invested in the stock for
example bernard arnold already owns 47
percent of lvmh so pumping up his stake
to 55 or 60 probably wouldn't motivate
him that much more
as a result board members are able to be
much more strict with their compensation
plans requiring these ceos to not only
put up time but put up results a great
example of milestone-based investing is
elon musk and tesla
elon musk receives no salary no bonus
and no time-based equity the only way
for him to earn more stock is to reach
the milestones outlined in this
compensation plan
as you can see these plans consist of
both market cap milestones and
operational milestones and he must hit
both of these numbers to be compensated
when these milestones were established
in 2018 tesla's market cap was just 59
billion dollars so reaching a 650
billion market cap was quite an
ambitious goal but elon has since
crossed these numbers which has given
him paydays worth tens of billions it
should also be noted though that if he
didn't reach his ambitious milestones
within 10 years he would have gotten no
compensation for 10 years of work this
is obviously rather harsh so many
companies tend to go for a more softened
approach they'll often combine
time-based vesting with milestone-based
vesting to create a hybrid vesting model
this way ceos don't have to achieve
insane growth numbers to be paid but at
the same time they can't just stand back
their time at the top either for example
this was one of the caveats that apple
introduced to tim's compensation plan in
2013. they clarified that apple must
also beat the s p 500 for tim to receive
his full compensation for a company like
apple beating the s p 500 throughout the
2010s wasn't that challenging of a goal
but it did introduce some level of
accountability
alright so companies use time and a
milestone based vesting to keep
executives loyal to the company over the
long term but what about during the
meantime for example from tim cook's
perspective it's great that he could
receive up to 1 million apple shares in
10 years but how can you enjoy the
benefits of that right now
this is obviously a rich person problem
but the solution is rather interesting
to discuss
the answer to this problem is usually
debt while tim couldn't sell most of the
stock he received in 2011 he could use
it as collateral
now trying to collateralize rsu income
or restricted stock income is not the
easiest of tasks for us normal people
but for company leaders this is rather
easy and it's not just because they're
in a powerful position the main reason
is that the items that they're trying to
buy are usually a small fraction of
their income for example tim recently
bought a 9.1 million house i have a
feeling that he just paid cash for this
property given that he bought this house
right after his stock compensation
unlocked but it wouldn't have been that
hard for him to take out a mortgage
either given that the house cost less
than 1 30 of his compensation plan
similarly elon took out 61 million worth
of mortgages in 2019 which was likely a
large amount compared to his cash
reserves but a miniscule portion
compared to its net worth this reasoning
obviously does not apply to the average
person who is buying a house that's
worth two to five times their gross
income for billionaires though this
strategy doesn't just apply to housing
it applies to basically every facet of
their life whether they're trying to buy
a private jet or twitter
also this strategy isn't just a
workaround stock vesting periods either
there's loads of benefits to leveraging
debt from maximizing returns and
minimizing taxes to benefiting from
inflation so these stock vesting periods
are just even more reason to take out
debt for these billionaires
everything we've covered so far accounts
for the vast majority of ceos it's
usually just a case of borrowing against
your rsus to fund your lifestyle until
you unlock your compensation packages
there are a few dozen people in the
world however who have significantly
more power for example no one can
prevent jeff bezos bill gates or elon
musk from selling their initial stakes
in the company so technically these guys
could try to sell all of their stock in
one goal and crash the market but given
that these guys are founders this is
extremely rare but it does happen from
time to time
and i don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that one of the ceos that was bold
enough to do this was steve jobs in 1985
steve jobs got entangled in months of
vicious battles with their ceo at the
time john scully and as you would guess
this eventually resulted in him being
ousted in september of 1985. out of rage
steve would go ahead and sell his entire
11 steak in apple except for one share
looking back at apple stock during the
time it doesn't actually look like apple
fell that much when steve actually sold
rather most of the sell-off took place
leading up to steve being fired by the
time steve departed the company the
stock was down a painful 77 from their
all-time high so while steve selling his
entire stake was a monumental event his
sale itself didn't impact the stock too
much given that most of the fear was
already priced in another example of a
foundry selling out is travis kalanick
and uber like steve jobs travis was
ousted from uber after months of
boardroom battles in december of 2019
and he of course sold all of his talk
right after he was ousted what's
interesting though is that he also sold
near the bottom just like steve jobs now
uber is at even lower levels today but
that's besides the point
the point is that by the time a founder
sells all of their shares in a rage fit
the stock is already in the toilet so
their selling itself doesn't hurt it all
that much if they were to just randomly
sell out of the blue though the stock
would no doubt get obliterated
aside from loose cannon examples most
founder ceos cash out extremely
strategically for example jeff bezos
sells a few billion dollars worth of
stock every year but he doesn't do so
without months of warning and he sells
in small digestible batches so the stock
price is really affected by his sales
likely the closest example to randomly
selling out of the blue is elon's recent
sale for twitter
in late april elon sold 8.5 billion
worth of tesla stock for about one
percent of the company this led to tesla
stocks selling off about 10 by the time
he finished selling this means that
selling one percent of the company
correlated to about a 10 sell-off so if
a founder was to sell 10 out of the blue
that would likely cause the stock to
crash 70 or 80 percent and that's not
even taking into account that the
selloff will accelerate as the foundry
continues to sell the only way for a
founder to sell out of such a position
is to spend decades slowly selling their
stock just like bill gates did when
microsoft went public in 1986 bill gates
owned 45 percent of microsoft today he
owns just 1.34 of the company now this
1.34 stake is still worth 25 billion
dollars but given that bill gates has
over 100 billion dollars the vast
majority of his wealth is no longer in
microsoft this makes him one of the most
liquid billionaires in the world but to
get to this position it took him at 36
years and if any other mega cap founder
wants to cash out without destroying
their stock this is really the only
option they have as well
and that's how ceos cash out of their
massive positions if you were the
founder of a mega cap company would you
holler your stick to your grave or would
you slowly sell off like bill comment
that down below also drop a like if you
wish you had rich people problems
instead and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
our videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one